um we're moving on to the uh brexit
today those negotiations in public
got even worse
and so i'm afraid of that as i've said i
don't believe that okay
the prime minister exasperated by brexit
questions
contradicting his own cabinet ministers
dealing with resignation threats
and doubling down today's challenge was
handling the domestic fallout this man
a senior scottish lawyer and the
advocate general didn't want to have to
say he was part of a government
willingly breaking international law
this was him just yesterday
the idea that the executive can enter
into atresia at the level of
international law
and then rely upon that to
to to to displace primary legislation
passed by the
the domestic parliament is i would
respectfully suggest extraordinary
but that meant contradicting the
northern ireland secretary who told mps
a week ago
it did breach international law brandon
lewis made
clear today he was right i've spoken
to lord keane and i have to say and
looking at the specific question that uh
my uh
my honorable friend asked me last week
he agrees the answer is the
correct answer so you were answering the
question so
in a in a limited way the proposals do
breach international legal agreements
the answer i gave was a very clear
answer to a very specific question
but today lord keem quit his ministerial
job saying he
tried and failed to fudge the issue
even as a compromise with tory rebels
over the bill
was in the offing tonight boris johnson
has struck a deal to quell the tory
rebellion
he's authorized a vote in the commons if
and when he feels he needs to break
international law it's enough for most
of the rebels on the tory benches
but not for lord keane nor likely to
satisfy the european union
the result of the compromise is still
that legislation to break the withdrawal
agreement
is heading for the statute books
brussels remains worried
i remind you of the words of margaret
thatcher i quote
britain does not break treaties and
after warnings from congress
warmer words from senior figures in the
trump administration
we trust the united kingdom well i am
confident they'll get it right we've
made clear
uh our view of the importance of the
good friday agreements we know the
complexity of the situation we've done
what we can
to provide assistance where we can in
the end
this will be a set of decisions with
respect to this that the united kingdom
makes
tory tensions heal today but divisions
with the eu remain
the evergreen statement of british
politics
sam coates sky news